hey guys welcome to another episode of
the Wednesday checkup it feels like we
haven't done one of those intros in a
while that's cuz we've been busy talking
about the novel coronavirus today we're
gonna be looking at some of the most
common conspiracy theories I've seen and
heard out there Shane Dawson I'm looking
at you we're doing the medical version
medical conspiracy time the government
introduced the corona virus in 2018 and
Bill Gates was somehow responsible Bill
and Melinda Gates Foundation is one of
the most humanitarian foundations in the
world financially speaking they're
literally doing everything they can to
eradicate disease bring fresh water to
people and we're gonna blame this on
them Japanese doctors treating kovat 19
cases say that you should insure your
mouth and throat are moist never dry so
make sure you're taking a few sips of
water every 15 minutes skeptical to the
source I don't know if necessarily
Japanese doctors came out and said this
but there's partial truth to it if you
have dry mucous membranes they are more
likely to crack when they crack you
actually have a higher possibility of
getting infected with a bacteria or
virus so yeah you should be staying well
hydrated you should be drinking will it
protect you 100%
no but it's a good way to make sure that
you're doing the best you can to stay
healthy hand dryers are effective at
killing coronavirus I don't think that's
the case it certainly hasn't been proven
also CDC recommends drying your hands
through the air dry method which is you
just naturally let your hands dry or
using a paper towel reason being there
was a study that I actually talked about
on this channel that showed those ultra
high speed dryers actually blow bacteria
and viruses all over the place
especially if you don't wash your hands
well with this virus having fecal-oral
spread meaning that toilet syncs can be
quite messy especially in public
restrooms you don't want to be blowing
that bacteria and viruses all over the
place so no I don't think air dryers
will kill the virus and I don't think
you should be using them you can create
your own hand sanitizer using Tito's
vodka I was almost gonna say like yeah
it's possible to create your own not
with vodka
not with Tito's vodka I actually think
Tito's vodka came out and had to make a
statement on this
because people were doing this based off
a tick-tock video no you cannot use
Tito's vodka which i think is only 40%
alcohol to create a hand sanitizer like
that is just not recommended if you're
going to be using some kind of
disinfectant the recommendation would be
to use rubbing alcohol
that being said soap and water soap and
water soap and water gargling with salt
water or vinegar will eliminate the Cova
dean coronavirus we have no evidence of
that I actually do recommend salt water
gargles to a lot of my patients not for
eliminating viruses just because it
suits a sore throat if you have mucus
buildup it helps clear the mucus
especially if you're like post nasal
drip or a really chronic sore throat but
to kill the virus we don't have evidence
of that also this virus seems to be very
infectious in comparison to the
influenza virus for example so if it
touches your mucous membranes
right away it's gonna start infecting
the rest of your body it has a long
incubation period but a quick infection
period if that makes any sense
coronavirus originated with Chinese
people eating bats from open-air markets
okay I heard this one and initially I
was almost ready to buy into that
because you know other cultures eat
different animals so I wasn't one to
judge however when I looked into this I
found that the initial picture that
started this reporting actually didn't
come from China it came from a reporter
that was eating in an Asian country not
China some kind of local delicacy
nothing to do with the cuisine that's
actually consumed in China so no we have
no evidence of this coming from bat soup
we need to stop that we initially
thought that this virus started in bats
somehow made its way to humans probably
through a mutation there could have been
an intermediate carrier along the way so
perhaps a bat passed it to another
animal and then we got it to humans we
don't know that yet we're gonna be
investigating and again let's think
smart here we're trying to combat this
prevent spread flatten the curve I
mentioned that in my other video which
basically decreases the strain that's
put on our healthcare systems what's the
use in talking about bats
outside of getting clicks the most
dangerous or at-risk place you can go is
a train or subway the most dangerous
place you can probably go is a hospital
or an emergency room with people
sneezing and coughing all over the place
that is why we've been directing
patients to call in ahead of time to
figure out if their symptoms are mild
enough so we can get them to stay home
so they don't spread their virus and
they don't catch anyone elses one of the
biggest problems we face in the hospital
is known as nosocomial infection I know
it's a mouthful basically means that you
got sick from being in the hospital if
you notice doctors are always trying to
get all the tests done give you all your
treatments so that we can send you home
from the hospital it's not because we
don't enjoy having you there it's
because we don't want you to catch a
disease accidentally in the hospital it
happens there's sick people all around
some people don't wash their hands well
they sneeze in the hallway you walk
through it there's all sorts of issues
so while I do think being a crowded
subway is not good being in a place
where there's a lot of sick people is
probably a tad worse that's why you
should be going only in cases of
emergency or when you need serious
medical advice or help that's why most
routine procedures surgeries
well checks all have been pushed aside
in order to prevent patients from coming
in and catching kovat 19 The Simpsons
predicted the corona virus this Simpsons
the novel's know no one could have
predicted this yes we knew that there
was a possibility of another pandemic
happening it happens with each
generation I think it happens the last
one that to me rings the biggest bell is
the Spanish flu of 1918 that claimed
millions of lives hopefully now with
modern medicine our ability to
communicate our ability to create
technology like vaccines and antiviral
medications rather quickly hopefully
we're gonna do a better job an Irish
company is preparing to release rapid
kovat 19 testing kits which can provide
results in 15 minutes that would be
awesome because we need more testing
kits and if we can get them done quickly
very important however these tests
especially the rapid ones need to be
heavily scrutinized through clinical
trials because we need to establish the
sensitivity and specificity of those
tests both of those need to be high I'll
explain each of them a test that has
high sensitivity is
for screening meaning taking general
people in the population and trying to
find out if they have a specific disease
in a highly sensitive test you have few
false negatives on a highly specific
test you have few false positives the
ideal way of doing this is you give
someone as a screening test a highly
sensitive one and then you can give them
a highly specific test to confirm that
diagnosis now in a test like this where
you're testing people who are already
sick it's not necessarily screening it's
more diagnostic and a good diagnostic
test has both high sensitivity and
specificity
there are many supplements and other
cures that can fight off the corona
virus we have zero evidence for any of
those statements and I'm so proud of the
FDA for prosecuting those individuals
trying to make claims like this John
Oliver had a segment of someone trying
to sell silver as a way to get rid of
the virus no no and if you're a
supplement manufacturer or you have your
own line of supplements please do not
use this as a moment to brand your
product that is a cheap shot praying at
folks vulnerabilities at a very
sensitive time we should be banding
together not trying to figure out how to
make a buck off each other for women in
wuhan have given birth to babies who do
not have the corona virus unlike their
mothers there's been some evidence
showing that what we call vertical
transmission from the mother to the baby
inside the uterus there isn't
transmission that's not to say can't
happen but the evidence for it does look
promising we're hoping it stays that way
I do recommend checking out mama dr.
Jones she does a fantastic job talking
all things OBGYN coronavirus included
links down below here's a playlist of
some medical memes for you to learn and
laugh roam because laughter is good
medicine and here's another playlist off
my reddit series check it out which one
you're gonna click on while you stay
happy and healthy
[Music]